[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of beginner breakdown my name as
always is Alex and I'm excited to be
showing you tonight's uh topic so I've
done some stuff like this before
um where I take one of the pieces in the
game and do kind of an overall analysis
of what are some of the major factors of
this piece so we did that with I believe
the night so far and
um The Rook so feel free to check out
those videos
today we're going to talk about the most
ambitious piece on the chessboard which
is actually
depending on who you ask not even a
piece at all we're going to look at the
pawns
now the pawns are I call them the most
ambitious for two reasons one because
they only move forward right so they're
never looking back they're never looking
to the side they're only looking forward
um and because they're the only piece
that has the ability to change right and
they can improve if they make it all the
way to their goal by forward progress
then they can promote
um so pawns are really weird they got a
lot of weird rules with them we're not
going to be going over exactly the rules
for them today so like on passant and
that kind of thing if you're not sure
some of those feel free to do a little
checking up on your own but we are going
to talk about some of just the really
basic things that are good to know and
might be helpful to you when dealing
with pawns
the first thing about Pawns
and I'm going to kind of go through the
stages of the game so like the opening
and then the middle game and then the
end game when we think about Pawns in
the opening I think there's really two
really important things right one is you
want them to occupy or control these
Center squares so you know playing moves
like E4 E5 D4 D5 are very classical very
principled openings
um
controlling the center is a good thing
on its own and getting the pawns out of
the way not only helps you do that but
also will allow you to develop your
other pieces easier
so that's really the main thing
however you also you it's not just that
you want them to control the center you
also don't want to move your Pawns in a
way that's going to endanger your king
so often in the beginning it's best to
start with these Center ones
occasionally you'll see someone start
with like one of the wing Pawns
but generally these are not as strong
openings most of the time maybe if you
only push it one it can be okay a little
more conservative The Rook Pawn is also
usually not so good sometimes a beginner
strategy is to play something like bring
the pawn out to develop The Rook which
makes sense as The Rook is an active
piece unfortunately in the long run this
is not a very good way to play because
this Rook is going to become a big
Target and it's just kind of clunky out
in the middle of the board it would
usually prefer to stay on the back row
hitting a long line
but today's not about Rooks today's
about pawns and besides controlling the
center they really in the beginning
serve as a shield for really all of your
pieces but most importantly your king
this is why
um you know one of probably one of the
most famous ways to get a Checkmate in
the beginning besides the scholars made
or the form of Checkmate is the Fool's
mate this is the fastest way to lose a
game of chess and there's a few
variations on how it can happen but the
basic idea is white is going to move
these two pawns the g-pawn up two F Pawn
one or two it doesn't make a difference
and you'll notice that this opens up
this really uh
important diagonal there's now an Avenue
to attack the king and so black can play
Queen to H4 on move two and this is
actually Checkmate the game is over and
it doesn't matter whether this Pawn is
up one or two this Pawn could be back
one space as well but as long as these
two pawns have moved and the queen is
able to develop that's all it takes
because no piece can block this check
and the King has nowhere safe to move
so in the beginning you want the pawns
to be controlling the center and you
also want to recognize their job as a
shield
um kind of the inverse of that is true
so something that I've talked about
before the opening principles right the
first one is control the center second
one is develop your pieces you know get
your Knights Bishops into the game
especially and the third one is keep
your king safe
you can look at all of those and also
kind of invert them so we could say if
you're going to play a move in the
opening that actually you know inhibits
your opponent taking space in the center
or that stops them from developing their
pieces to good squares or that endangers
their King then those are also going to
be very good right if it's good for you
it's bad for them and so on and so forth
so uh not only do you want to use them
to guard your king
but also you want to use them to attack
your opponent's king So this comes I
think most clearly when one side is
castled in One Direction and The Other
Side the other one so one side King side
castles the other side Queen side
castles
because now you'll have your pawns let's
imagine black queen side castles here
these pawns especially these three are
really going to want to stay back keep
the king safe whereas we're going to
want to launch these pawns at our
opponent and the opposite is true for
white and I want to show you that as
kind of an example I want to look at a
game that I found that happened quite a
while ago between allopin and harmonist
and in this position alapan had white
we're going to start with him
so pawn moves to E4 E5 Knight F3 Knight
C6 all very standard stuff you know like
we said controlling the center
developing our pieces
and uh alapin plays this move C3 so this
is the ponziani
um Alpha is actually more famous for
playing C3 against the Sicilian the C3
Sicilian is kind of just named after him
but we see this C3 idea here as well
um doing really two main things one it
is primarily supporting the pawn to D4
so white would love to play this Pawn to
D4 but if we do it too quickly then
they're just going to take and it's not
going to be as good now that we have a c
Pawn supporting this push if black
captures we can recapture and maintain
our strong Center and we're going to see
the importance later on of having what
some people would call a pawn Duo right
two pawns right next to each other and
especially one in the center
um harmonist here plays actually I think
the most precise move which is Pawn to
D5 immediately disrupting uh White's
plans here in the center there's not
time to push D4 now because we will lose
this Pawn on e4 and it gets a little
complicated
um instead of pushing or taking alapan
plays Queen to A4 putting a pin on this
Knight and some pressure now because
this piece is pinned it's it can't move
and it's not protecting anything anymore
so there's now a threat of maybe playing
Knight takes E5 and putting additional
pressure on this Knight
and to kind of alleviate that harmonist
plays this move F6 which is a bit
unusual
um not for this position in this
position actually it's one of the best
moves but generally as we said you don't
usually want to move these pawns
um and what's the reason for that well
it's not in the center and this one
actually is giving that same diagonal to
your king that we saw before
so what's the difference between this
and the previous position
well the main difference is
there's not actually a way to attack
this right now this bishop is
undeveloped so it can't really get over
here and alopin already moved his Queen
out of the way it's now on the other
side of the board so in order to take
advantage of this weakness he would have
to you know reroute his queen or develop
the bishop and get this Knight out of
the way it's going to take a few moves
which means harmonis is going to have
plenty of time to shore up this
defensive weakness and it's worthwhile
for him to defend the center in this way
so that's why this move is played even
though it's usually atypical
alapin continues with pressure on the
night with Bishop to B5 now just
threatening to capture twice and Fork
the king in The Rook
and here harmonist responds with Knight
E7 Bishop D7 will seems sensible as well
um but it also makes sense to develop
this Knight seeing as it can no longer
get to F6
Pawn takes D5 Queen takes D5
castles and Bishop E6 and now we can see
that even though the dark squared Bishop
is a little trapped by this Knight
that's okay because harmonist is looking
to queenside Castle
which happens very quickly D4 Pawn takes
C takes and queen side Castle
and now that we have kind of clarified
the position a little bit we understand
what's happening
um as we talked about before one very
general idea with the pawns is you want
to keep the ones in front of your king
safely shielding it
and you want to uh if you're the
opponent you want to try and break
through that Shield so white is looking
to keep these pawns you know tucked back
safely guarding the king occupying and
controlling these really important
squares near the king
whereas White's going to want to push
the A and B pawns down the line to try
and break through Black's kind of
Queen's High castle and black is going
to be doing the opposite on our side the
question is who's going to be able to do
it first and how are they going to
mobilize their pieces to assist in this
matter
so let's see what happens here okay
Knight to C3 attacking the queen gaining
some time
Queen goes to F5 out of the way
Bishop to E3 defending D4 and lining up
with this Castle also just developing
and pawn to G5 so harmonist isn't
wasting any time immediately begins to
try and storm the castle
Rook F to C1 lining up with the king so
these pawns have been pushed initially
but we can see that pressure is starting
to mount against harmonist here there's
a lot of just p a lot of Peace activity
and a lot of potential for threats to be
released in this position
H5 continuing forward and now alapin
plays B4 beginning to move forward with
the Pawns
H4
and Knight back to E1 this is kind of an
interesting move perhaps preparing for
pontu G4 than where the knight's gonna
have to move anyway and going to E1
likely just because of where the Knight
wants to Route
um it could be going you know in this
direction maybe uh or possibly here
later on it's also controlling some of
these squares
so let's see so G4 as we predicted and
now the Knight would have had to move
anyway
uh Bishop to D3 pulling back
attacking the queen and now we can also
see another reason for Knight to E1 to
support this bishop and getting out of
the way to allow the pawns to continue
to charge forward
Queen to H5 getting out of the way and
pawn to B5
the Knight doesn't really have any good
squares we can see that the queen
controls these two the pawn is defended
adequately on D4 and certainly controls
so the only real move here is Knight to
B8 which unfortunately allows now Queen
takes A7 as the Knight was previously
defending that pawn and we can see
Black's position already starting to
slightly crumble
Bishop to H6 activating this piece
defending the Rooks maybe putting some
Challenge on White's Bishop on E3
and white simply continues by moving in
for the kill Knight to A4 controlling B6
potentially preparing Pawn 2 B6 to try
and break through put more pressure
Rook to D6 looking to try and mitigate
some of this perhaps hoping to reroute
and get a strong attack in the center
but also just hoping to control the
sixth rank a little better and maybe do
something to stop this but unfortunately
there's a really nice move played Now by
alapin who recognizes that with the
Knight out of the way the Rook that he
put on C1 so long ago is now pinning
this Pawn
allowing for Knights to B6 check
you could move the king but then the
Knight Falls so Rook takes and queen
takes B6
now Checkmate is threatened from the
rook and the queen so Pawn to C6 but
because this Pawn has already advanced
it's able to tear down the shields B
takes C6 knight from E takes C6
Rook a to B1 making another uh nearly
Checkmate threat the king would have an
escape but it's not going to be pretty
and queen to F7 to defend and in this
position alapan played one more move
before harmonist resigned he played the
move a really beautiful Bishop to A6
putting just too much pressure there's
no way to hold this position
um and there's a few ideas you can't
take this bishop because then uh Queen
takes B8 because again this Knight is
still pinned our Rook on the C file is
too powerful so the king will move and
we get a Checkmate very quickly
okay what else is there you can't take
what if the Knight takes instead
well if the Knight takes then there's
actually a really pretty sacrifice Rook
takes C6 Pawn takes Queen takes A6 so
we've sacked The Rook for two nights
which is uh good for us King moves and
check
we could take this free rook but you can
do even better with Queen to a free
check
we could take this queen
but you can also still do better here
with Queen to A5 and Checkmate is forced
because if you move this way
I have mate in two
and if you move this way
I have maintenance one the bishop can no
longer block the only other move would
be to sack the queen which I will take
and follow up with a Checkmate so
regardless there's not really anything
that black can do to get out of this
and it will result in a Checkmate very
quickly so harmonists resigned in this
position but I do like this game because
it shows the the basic idea you know
both players pushing forward trying to
break through it just so happened that
even though harmonists started the pawn
storm sooner uh their peace activity
wasn't quite altogether and White's
pieces were coordinated and able to line
up a really nice attack
so that's kind of the basics of how to
use the pawn with the king the thing
with the King and we're going to look at
a few of the other pieces are the king's
relationship with the pawns is very
proportional based on how many pieces
are on the board so the more pieces on
the board the more the king is going to
use pawns as a shield to keep the king
safe
versus the last pieces are on the board
then the more the king actually becomes
a very active piece and will actually be
involved in assisting the pawns on their
journey to promotion
um so that's really what you want to
keep in mind with the the pawns and the
King now we're going to look at the
ponds with every other piece so we're
going to look at the Knights the Bishops
and the Rooks and the Queens we're kind
of going to skip over because the main
concern now is about the pawn structure
and how that is going to interact with
various pieces
and the queen is a you know powerful and
versatile enough piece that she can kind
of adjust and adapt to whatever
structure the pawns are in so she
doesn't have anything really specific
with how to play with the pawns but the
other piece is absolutely new
so to take an example of a few of that
we're going to start with the Bishops
how do the Bishops and the pawns
interact
so they do so in a few ways
but the first one is
this concept of like a good or a bad
Bishop
I need power
this thing is going to die
um
so for those who are unfamiliar I think
I give electron good and bad Bishops so
feel free to check that out if it's
online I don't remember if we streamed
it but the basics are
um really with any piece in order to
evaluate if it's doing something well or
not if it's a good or bad piece in the
position you need to determine
um
how active it is how much Mobility it
has right so there's a saying that a
night on the rim is grim or dim and
that's because a night on the edge of
the board is only going to control a
handful of spaces
that works versus
if a knight's in the center yeah yeah a
knight in the center is going to control
a whole lot more well we want to look at
the same with the Bishops so Bishops
prefer games that are open which we'll
look at in a second but they also look
at the color right because Bishops can
only occupy one color of the board we
call them like the light square and the
dark squared because of which squares
they can occupy
which squares the pawns are on actually
matters a whole lot
so notice in this position that all of
White's pawns are on the dark squares
and all of Black's pawns are on these
light squares
and now look at the color Bishops they
have we both have a light squared Bishop
so because of that white is actually
doing a lot better even though the
material is almost equal I think lights
up a Pawn on the materials very close to
even but white is significantly better
because their Bishop is actually able to
maneuver around in between all of their
own pawns and simply make threats
against their opponent's Pawns
whereas Black's Bishop here uh is
relegated purely to defense it can only
keep its pawns defended but it can't
actually maneuver that well it can't go
through them or past them
and it can't make any threats against
White's Pawns
so when considering how the pawns work
with your Bishops right if you have
Bishops left on the board or your
opponent does you really want to look at
where your pawns are placed if they're
on the right color square and how you
can you know activate your Bishop
one of the most popular openings
nowadays for white is the London defense
there's by the London system
and it has this idea where
um white basically will occupy all of
these light squares I'm just going to
play some sample moves here
but you know something like this and
White's going to continue development
but the basic idea is white is putting
all their pawns on these dark squares
and forming this nice defensive
formation and so they very quickly bring
their Bishop out on the outside of that
formation so that it's able to you know
move around and fight against Black's
pieces because if it's sitting here on
C1 it wouldn't be doing very much so
that's kind of the same principle here
is you want to be aware of how you're
using your pawns and what color they're
occupying
depending on what color Bishop you have
or your opponent has and so on and so
forth
another thing that the Bishops care
about in regards to pawns are you know
whether the position is open or closed
so when I say an open or closed position
you're looking specifically at these two
Center files the E and D file and
whether there are pawns occupying and
locked up there or not
so in this case the pawns are just
totally absent which means that Bishops
are going to be a lot better than the
knights right the knights don't mind
when pieces are locked up which we will
see later because they can jump around
and reposition themselves wherever they
need to go but Bishops like long open
diagonals where they can roam free and
attack a whole massive line
so uh the Bishops are actually
dominating white in this position is
significantly better because they have
the bishop pair whereas black with a
knight and a bishop is not as good
because these Bishops can just occupy so
much space
in contrast as we just mentioned
in this position this bishop is
dominated for two reasons one it's kind
of bad right we just talked about the
same color pawns as the bishop so it
can't really move as far but also
because these pawns are kind of locked
up now this is a knight instead of a
pawn but the idea is the same mobility
of all these pawns is severely
restricted which means that the bishop
is not going to be able to do much
because these pawns can't move out of
its way whereas the Knight can jump
around again to wherever it needs to to
get through these defenses it can it
switches colors every turn and so
anything that's reducing mobility in the
position which with the pawns happens a
lot right any time where I don't want to
push a pawn because I'll lose it like a
backwards spawn or an isolated Pawn that
can't really move because it's not
protected in front
pawns that are doubled so any two pawns
that are on the same file that can't
move very easily any positions like that
the knights are going to prefer
okay so that's Knights and Bishops and
we looked at the king first now let's
look at the Rooks real quick
so Rooks and pawns also have an
interesting relationship and I'd say
it's fairly similar to the Bishops any
piece that attacks in a straight line
whether it's the Queen the bishop The
Rook all of them are doing a lot better
in the game when they have access to
Long Open Spaces
so in this position it is white to move
and there's actually one move that's
just absolutely crushing in this
position I I know I haven't really
interacted with the chat or our audience
here too much yet so I'll give you a
little bit of a chance to do so now if
you want to take a look at this position
for white and see if you can come up
with a really good idea
what what would be a great way for white
to improve the position
all right someone in the chat uh
squizard kid I believe is your name uh
you have the right idea it's Pawn takes
Pawn on uh D5 and the reason is because
we're going to open this file for the
rook and allow our piece to really get
in the game
and this position is actually so
problematic like allowing this Rook to
invade is so bad for black that the
computer says the best move here is to
not recapture it's to to lock up this
position
allowing us to defend our extra Pawn so
the the computer would rather let us
just have that pawn totally for free
then give our Rook any room to invade
and I think it's justified in doing so
because well you can't really take with
the Rook because then I just win this
Pawn
and if you take with the pawn
then now you can see how dangerous The
Rook becomes it's going to invade on the
seventh rank and if you don't act very
quickly so one you need to defend this
Pawn somehow so you can either push it
or move the Rook to defend but whatever
you do
I can now double up the Rooks and take
almost total control
and very quickly yeah you can't do this
because this is a checkmate
so if black plays some other move
something like this let's say just
anything else van white can very quickly
double their Rooks on the seventh and
this is
I mean black is almost getting
checkmated here
um you're attacking these Pawns
and yeah there's just really nothing you
can do the position is crumbling and
totally lost all because
what was able to invade with these Rooks
um because white knew to open the
position with these pawns so having like
a position where there's tension here
right these two pawns can take each
other or not they could push past but
having this kind of option open can be
really helpful when you have pieces like
Rooks and Bishops that like long Open
Spaces
um fat chicken legs in the chat asks
what is the best opening for beginners
it's a tough question there's a lot of
really good ones
um I would say openings where you
understand the ideas really well and
they don't require a lot of long
memorization of forced lines
so there's a lot of different
possibilities there really depends but I
think I did a lesson on openings that I
would encourage you to check out
okay another thing with the pawns this
isn't like a major thing but this is a
pattern that I see a lot in beginner
games
and I want to show it through just kind
of a sample game that one of my students
sent me I've adapted it slightly to
illustrate the point a little better
um
but let's just take a look at this game
so it starts out the same as that allop
and harmonist game
but this time it's an Italian so Bishop
to C4
Bishop C5 D3
and you know just some normal
development moves a lot of beginners
have probably played a game that looks
something like this
and we can understand most of the ideas
now in this position Bishop G5 Knight E7
is an unusual move
uh one because we've already moved this
piece but it's doing two things it's
breaking the PIN
from this queen and also even though we
can double the pawns here if white wants
the kingside castle then maybe this is a
bit dangerous you know activating this
Rook opening up the file for it to
attack
so it seems at least reasonable now
White's probably better if they make
this trade and then just Queen side
Castle but regardless
that's a little beyond the scope of this
lecture Queen D2
A5
White kingside Castles and black plays
C6 and my question to you is in this
position it's white to move
what is the threat because there is kind
of a A Veiled Threat in this position
that some people won't notice
so yeah take a second in the chat if you
want to try and figure it out but
there's a very serious threat that black
is kind of looking to play if you're not
careful
what is it that we have to be watching
out for
and if you're watching later feel free
to pause the video but hello play chess
uh and Donnie have both found the idea
lifetime 42 yeah so this is a pattern
that's really familiar to some players
it happens a lot and it's called the
nose Arc pattern I don't actually know
why I don't know if it's like a two by
two thing but the idea is
we are going to trap this bishop with
our Pawns
so if white isn't very careful and just
play some move then Pawn to B5 okay and
we look and say okay where can this
bishop go well this Pawn is defended
this square is defended the square is
defended the square is attacked so we
have to back off and now A4 and you're
like wait how on Earth did this happen
I'm going to now have to sacrifice my
Bishop for a pawn just because I got
trapped like this how does this happen
and it's very subtle
I believe in the game originally sent by
my student it was slightly different it
was a little less subtle in that game
the moves were C6
castles B5 pushing Bishop back and then
A5 and now it's very clear what the
threat is right it's very sequential but
because the order happened a little
differently
first A5 with the idea that okay we're
gonna slowly take away these spaces and
see if they notice and then we're not
going to give them this extra move
because if you play it you know the the
first way
then now in this position it's a lot
easier to see that A4 is a threat and I
can just play some move like Pawn to A3
and be alive
but if you play something like this A5
and then C6 I don't know maybe C6 is
looking towards D5 or you know to open
up this queen there's a lot of different
reasons this move might have happened
and so someone might not be immediately
thinking Pawn to B5 N2 A4
so keep an eye out for this pattern
there's two actual kind of positions or
like openings that it's really famous
for one of them is uh the Sicilian
Defense so here we could look at a game
E4 C5 Knight F3 Knight C6 Knight C3 Pawn
to D6 Bishop B5
already there's a little bit of a
potential danger here because if we just
play the pawn to A6 then now this bishop
cannot Retreat to A4 if they go like
back to in the middle then it's probably
fine but if they go to A4 then they fall
in for the Trap because our Pawn is
already on C5 so Pawn to B5
Bishop B3 C4 and the bishop is
completely trapped the same pattern here
and one more example actually comes out
of the Roy Lopez opening this one is a
little more complex so I'm not going to
go super super deep into it but the
basic ideas
are we enter the Roy Lopez or Spanish
opening with Bishop to B5
Pawn to A6 a very normal response here
Bishop A4
D6 and
white is kind of uh there's a very
logical move that a lot of people would
want to play which is Pawn to D4
um you know crashing forward opening up
room to develop the bishop it's a very
sensible move in a lot of positions but
here it runs into the issue Pawn to B5
okay Bishop goes to B3 getting out of
the way and now Knight takes D4 a really
nice move with the idea that we're
grabbing upon and forcing light to
recapture
takes takes Queen takes you know trying
to pick that pawn back up but now you
can sort of see we're going to get a
Tempo on this queen with C5 the Queen's
gonna have to move out of the way and
we're going to push to C4
C5 and white can try and play a little
tricky with Queen to D5 you know
threatening to win our Rook not giving
us time but if we simply play a move
like Bishop E6 attacking the queen and
defending the Rook with our Queen
the queen will have to move
we can say they move to C6 again to
complicate it with a check but
once again simply dropping the bishop
back is good enough and there's nothing
here to do you have to Save the Queen
which allows C4 and the bishop is
eventually trapped
so just do keep an eye out for this
pattern again you don't have to know it
as complex as this specific opening
um
but this kind of idea of moving the
pawns forward sometimes obviously
sometimes subtly but trapping the bishop
back taking away all these squares is a
pattern that I do see a lot in lower
level games so I wanted to share that
with you here
another thing that the pawns are really
good at is
Forks
so in this position the move is probably
fairly obvious but Pawn Forks are
something that's really simple and also
really easy to overlook because you
don't often look for you know how is
this piece going to
help me tactically right we're thinking
more strategically about the structure
which color is it on is it connected or
not you know
um
but when you have an opportunity right
when two of your opponent's pieces are
just sort of next to each other but not
right next to each other sometimes
you'll have this opportunity for a
really nice Pawn Fork so do keep that in
mind as well
um one more example that I think is a
really fun one
is this position
in this position you probably can find
the move because I gave you a little bit
of a hint based on the topic but if
anyone wants to take a guess at the move
and the idea what is
White's kind of plan to gain an
advantage here actually in this position
we're actually down a little bit of
material notice how we only have a
bishop a knight versus two Bishops or
sorry two nights in a bishop so we're
down a night for I think a pawn although
one of those pawns is doubled so black
is really doing quite well here
uh except we have one nice tactical
resource
which yeah a few people in the chat are
already finding and it's this idea of
Pawn to C4 first displacing the Knight
and then moving farther forward to C5
which doesn't look like on its own it
would be very good because you're like
wait the bishop will just take it's not
actually a fork because that Pawn's not
defended but then you realize once this
Knight is out of the way our Rook will
pin the bishop to the king
and we get this really nice sequence you
cannot take because your Bishop is
pinned and this is an effective Fork
so do keep looking out for these one
famous example of like a pond Fork is
actually called the fork trick and it's
an opening that comes out of the Four
Knights um
and it's you know very simple we play
the four nights I'm sorry the three
nights uh I think there's a way to get
it in the four nights as well but
um
certainly in the three nights so
in this position white actually has
another pretty interesting move that I
think it's fairly even or balanced at
intermediate level but it can give a
nice Advantage at higher levels
if you know what you're doing
so in this position
it's white to move how can we gain an
advantage
some of you might play this position if
you do feel free to to share if you
don't this is a nice learning
opportunity here
uh D4 is I think a fine move
um
might be a little gambity but it's
probably possible to play
um
but yeah a few other people are finding
the idea and it's actually to make this
temporary sacrifice Knight takes E5 in
order
to put these two pieces now we can play
D4 and we're going to pick it up and so
we're actually getting a pawn here
because
um a lot of people will just take this
pawn and queen takes back this is
actually a bit of a problem for black
this doesn't get seen at the high levels
um because now okay we don't want to
move the Knight you're going to lose the
G7 Pawn so something like D6 and white
is basically going to get a lot of just
extra time and pressure
black is yet to Castle White is fully
Castle fully mobilized and ready to
start an attack
so instead of that often what happens at
higher levels when this is played and
this isn't played very often at higher
levels but it does happen is instead to
drop the bishop back to D6
and to take here
and it's still an even game but maybe
white has a slight Edge just from some
initiative this piece having to move
around a lot
so yeah so that's another useful example
of kind of Pawn Forks so keep those in
your back pocket as well a nice little
tactical resource and a lot of people
Overlook it at the beginning level
and now I want to look at a few
different kind of really
I guess critical Pawn structures they're
like the building blocks for almost
every other one I've talked about in
previous lectures on like weaknesses you
know double pawns and isolated pawns
connected pawns past pawns we'll talk
about those a little bit but I'm not
going to go through all of those since
I've done it in another video
but I do want to talk about these
structures
so here's the first one
um and all of these kind of names I
actually found in a book I believe it's
called just Pawn power or something like
that by Hans mock
um it's an old book but really good
information and he says if we're looking
at a position like this right where the
two pawns are just in the way then he
calls this the RAM and imagine like two
actual Rams you know ramming their heads
into each other and just locked in this
conflict where neither can gain an
advantage that's basically what's
happening here when the two pawns are
pushing each other it's a total impasse
the thing to know about this position
that is maybe not obvious at first
glance is that it actually is favoring a
side that's trying to defend rather than
attack
think about what I was saying earlier
with the knights and their Mobility so a
knight can kind of jump around and
maneuver and it does that better when
these pawns are stuck
Rams lock up a lot of space and make it
harder to do that Invasion so pieces
like the Bishops and the Rooks the
Queens have a harder time breaking
through
and additionally just notice that they
just occupy a lot of space in terms both
of where they are placed they can't move
and in terms of where they control right
this is a big chunk of the board
occupied by two little pawns
um so if you want to you know make an
attack in a position often you're going
to try and break down these locked pawns
try and trade or Force captures
sometimes even make sacrifices in order
to get them out of the way
another thing that I think the the ram
type position it shows us is one of the
big weaknesses of Pawns in general which
is actually you know there some people
could say okay they're weak from the
side or from behind or on you know these
long diagonals and all of that is true
but perhaps the biggest weakness they
have is the square right in front of
them and the reason is not only sure
they can be attacked from that way but
also because they don't have any means
to attack it and that's the only
Direction they can move if someone
controls the square in front of a pawn
whether it's by another Pawn or by
dropping a piece there then you really
just cut off everything that pawn can do
so that's something really really
important to keep in mind the square in
front of a pawn is one of its biggest
weaknesses
let's contrast this with a different
type of position
now the two pawns are looking at each
other and Hans kamak called this type of
position a lever
I think just because it literally maybe
looks like a lever but
um
the idea here is unlike the previous
position where it's just an impasse very
solid very locked up this is a very
tense position right there's a lot of
pressure on who is going to exchange
first or who's going to push past how is
this pressure going to be released but
right now there is the potential for a
capture
usually in chess this unless there's a
good reason to make an exchange
sides each side of the board will
usually prefer to continue to add
pressure to the position rather than
release it because if you you know make
this exchange with the pawns then often
whoever gets to recapture can gain space
or develop one of their pieces or maybe
gain some initiative
um so that's something to keep in mind
maybe a good example of that is
something in like some French structures
so a very common idea in you know these
French type structures
is
we're going to kind of can create this
tension here usually it's either with C5
or F6
um and kind of just continue to build on
it right so like some very normal
looking positions neither side wants to
make the trade because if you do you're
conceding something right if in this
position white simply takes then we are
helping black activate their pieces we
are undefending our E5 Pawn which
becomes a weakness
conversely if um if black takes well now
a lot of the opportunity to continue to
add pressure has gone away right it's
going to be easier now for white to
develop their pieces and you sort of see
the idea so that's just a very basic
rudimentary example of
this type of lever position where the
pawns are in tension so again it's just
some more stuff to keep in mind with
that
and perhaps one of the most important
things to think about is this idea of
Pawn Duos is what Hans calls it in the
book and a pawn Duo is just two pawns
that are next to each other sometimes
they're right next to each other
sometimes one is pushed forward
and so one defends the other is at the
top but these Duos are really really
important
um for a few reasons
Ted Bradley you call these pawns Bros I
love that these pawns are now Bros in my
mind and the idea with the Bros is they
cover each other's weaknesses so
remember how we talked about uh how the
scar right in front of a pawn is one of
its biggest weaknesses well if you have
a pawn that's right next to it or able
to move next to it then you're covering
that spot they can kind of leapfrog with
each other and help each other all the
way down the board
and just notice how much control they
actually exert right with four pawns on
the board we actually control this
entire rank
the entire fifth rank is attacked just
by two Pawns
um you can't make any other setup with
the pawns to do this to control the
whole row but if you have two of them
next to each other in this kind of nice
evenly spaced position then it works
which again goes to show just how
valuable these things are right both for
supporting each other and for
controlling space in general right this
is a lot of pressure to have in the
position so keep an eye out for forming
Pond Duos right you would always rather
have pawns be connected to each other
than disconnected when given the choice
I'll write another idea here so before I
kind of talk on this position uh let me
ask the question to you all
it is white to move in this position and
we have the option to trade Bishops
should we trade or should we not
uh there's really no other move to
consider here because
we can't defend this bishop so if we
don't trade and we don't retreat it then
we're going to lose it so why should we
trade or why should we not trade what do
you think
I see
pumpkin the cat Yes Trade someone else
said no someone says yeah
uh so we have a few back and forths I
like this debate
trade Bishop oh Bishop E5 I should say
yeah I did not consider this move Bishop
E5 is actually an interesting move to
consider as well the problem with Bishop
E5 I will tell you that is not the move
is even though it's going to help you
generate maybe a past Pawn Black's King
is just way too close
um it's going to be able to take this
pawn and still cover this one from
promoting so
that's sadly not going to work but
yeah so most people I think are seeing
the right idea we actually in this
position very much would like to trade
we're treating I think will result in a
draw I mean it's basically an even
position and black will be able to
re-coordinate themselves but because
black has allowed the trade in this
position
their King is going to be too far behind
and stuck
notice in this position that black
actually has no threats right now other
than just trading this but just winning
our Bishop right we can't allow that
um but that's the only threat the pawns
themselves are not making any threats
because even though they're equal with
these two doubled
this point is they're both completely
stumped they can't do anything
on their own I should say if you could
take some of these Pawns
excuse me sorry if you could take some
of these pawns then it would be fine but
this king is too far away because it has
a very important job
white has a past Pawn if Black's King
goes too far away this Pawn will run
but it doesn't have to because it has
you know part of these Duos
these Pond Bros are defending it in this
nice triangle formation
and so White's King is going to be free
to just March up the board and do
whatever they want because black can't
actually stop them you either have to
stop the King which allows the pawn to
move or you stay and stop the pawn which
allows the king to totally invade
so in this position
we can simplify because we recognize
that white has an incredible advantage
in this structure but black just has no
answer for
we have a threat of a past Pawn moving
forward to promotional
and black has no potential counter play
whatsoever without the king and they
will need the king so just
a play could continue something like
this
let's just see what the computer tries
to do against me
all right so they're going to stop but
now I can just push this Pawn the king
will have to go back and catch it and
now I can step in so this is what the
computer is suggesting and you can
imagine a lot of other ways this plays
out but black will eventually have to
concede something
um okay and now that we've looked at
this idea I want to move kind of we've
looked at kind of some basic structures
some terminology in the opening the
middle game and now we're into the end
game in the beginning how we look at the
and the middle game how we look at the
pawns is really all about structure
sometimes it's those nice tactical
opportunities to trap a piece or you
know get a fork but generally speaking
it is more in the structure once we get
to the end this is where everything
comes together towards Pawn promotion
because the way most games of Chess end
um other than maybe loss on time is
it's about both sides having a fairly
even
playing field but one side being
slightly more active with their pieces
or their king or one side being having
an extra Pawn or two and being able to
convert that into a win by promoting the
pawn
this example is really fascinating
because
in almost all cases if you have a king
that is in front of a pawn so in this
case this Pawn is going this way off the
board to promotion if you have a king in
front of a pawn it can almost always
promote if your king is far enough ahead
able to control the key squares
in this position
that is false even though this king is
way behind
and this king is way ahead because this
Pawn is on the edge it actually is a
draw
so something you may have heard is
captured towards the center with your
pawns I guess in general too but
capturing towards the center one because
it's going to alleviate this problem
probably the main reason is because the
center is usually more important and you
want pieces to control those squares so
often capturing towards the edge doesn't
make as much sense but also in this very
specific case if you have one extra pawn
it might not be enough
um in this position I believe it does
depend on Whose move it is in this
position with black to move black will
hold the draw if it was white to move I
think white actually does win because
white can play something like King B6
and the idea is white needs to keep our
King just out from getting there's two
things white needs to do here
um white needs to stop our King from
getting into this corner
because if our King can touch the A8
Corner before this Pawn gets there then
there's actually nothing white can do to
dislodge us they can either just move
around forever and do nothing or force a
stalemate
um to show kind of a very simple example
of that is if white plays really badly
here and just lets me take the corner
and there's actually just nothing that
white can do to get me out of it
they can move their King around and I
can just always stay in the corner
they will I could take the pawn I don't
even have to because at some point to
try and make progress they will push
and this is a stalemate because either
they move away from the pawn and I take
it or they move to defend it and I have
no legal moves
so that's one thing white needs to do
they need to stop me from doing that
which king B6 actually I think allows
the second thing they need to stop me
from doing is actually keeping this King
locked on this file because then I can
force a stalemate myself
so imagine something like this right
we're going to walk up the board I'm
going to continue to take opposition and
stop this king from ever leaving this
wall
and I'm just going to keep going back
and forth and either you were eventually
going to let me take the corner which we
already saw as a draw
or
you will just box yourself in with your
own Pawn
and this is also a stalemate
because I control all of these squares
so
um because of that this is like the
exception to the rule normally if your
king gets in front of the pawn you're
good in this case you you can't have it
be a rook Pawn just because if white is
winning with a rook Pawn it's the
exception not the rule
um so with problem promotion that's one
thing is you want to if you can if you
have the choice right between making a
rook Pawn or a non-rook pond you almost
always want to make a non-rook punt
um let's look at an example here of Pawn
promotion something else I think is
insightful
so in this position uh material is equal
both sides have four pawns and a rook
and the question is what can black do
here
to win right we would love to play our
pawn and promote but what should we do
to actually make sure that happens
all right yeah hello play chess has the
idea right if we just play Pawn to H2
then white can play Rook to B1 and will
be able to stop us so that's not going
to be any good
the actual really nice move here is to
sacrifice The Rook Rook to D1 a really
beautiful move because now the king will
take and actually get in the way of this
Rook controlling that square
so the reason I'm showing this example
is less about the pawns and more just to
show how valuable a past Pawn is right
because you can make any piece you need
usually it will be the queen but not
always
because you can do that then even
sacking a rook in order to get that
Queen is going to be worth it so always
keep the idea open of how can I help
support the pawn and so this is kind of
an edge case where we can actually just
blockade the file so that's a really fun
one
but there are some more common obstacles
that I want to walk through with you
so
um this position
don't worry so much about who's can
solve it that wasn't really my intention
um
it's more to notice the way these pawns
are oriented so
neither side here has past pawns but
it's for a different reason so
these two pawns are not passed either of
them because the other one is in the way
and I believe in the book uh Hans calls
this a mechanical obstruction or a
mechanical obstacle so like I will never
due to the mechanics of the game of
chess be able to promote this Pawn so
long as you have a Pawn on the same file
as me because they're just going to be
in their way forever and there's nothing
that they can do independently of the
other pieces
contrast that with these two
which neither of these are past pawns
because not of a mechanical issue it's
not about the game it's a dynamic issue
because whenever one of them moves
forward the other one will control that
square
so this one can be overcome but you have
to be more creative with it
those are like the two basic issues
and if we continue
we'll notice in a position like this
that what we want to look out for are
one
the mechanical problem do they have a
Pawn on the same file
who the uh do they have a Pawn on the
adjacent file right so like these two
and then ultimately the best kind of
Pawn is one where they don't have any of
that so this would be our true past Pawn
they can't stop it and either way with
their own pawns their own pieces are
going to have to get in the way and
that's usually we can find a way to
overcome that so this is the easiest
Pawn to promote and then you'll get a
pawn you know like uh say this one or
this one which it's possible with
careful play to promote
um if it was White's to move and we can
imagine some Kings on the board
somewhere then Pawn to D5 would be a
really nice move to force a trade and
create another pass Pawn over here
um so these Dynamic obstacles can be
overcome through strong play but a
mechanical issue is the hardest to
overcome in order to get a pawn like
this to promote I will actually have to
find a way to eliminate
the pawn in my way
something else about promotion
is similar to our first idea of
sacrifices
this is a really famous example and this
position it's white to move and Black's
King is far closer so if we try and you
know just move our King Black's King is
going to beat us to the pawns eat them
all up and win
so we don't have time to just wait we
have to do something quickly or black is
just going to win and there's actually a
way to do it in this position
um
and what you need to think about is your
goal here is if you get any one of your
three pawns to promote before black has
a chance even if they take the other two
if you can just get one to promote your
good so this is a hard example if you
haven't seen it before but if anyone
wants to take a shot at finding White's
winning idea here
then feel free to take a shot at the
best move and again you want to think
about which spaces the Pawn's control
and how can you force your way to get to
the end without your opponent being able
to stop you
so I'll give you a little bit of time to
think about this one
and I think I will have one more thing
after this and then we will switch over
but in this position white to move how
can we win
okay
B6 has been suggested by a few people
uh hello play chess I think has the
right idea so B6 suggesting a takes you
have to take this Pawn right if you
don't take this Pawn
um then I'm just going to take one of
your two whichever two you don't take
with right if say you push this one I
take and I promote so you have to take
and it doesn't actually make a
difference which one you take with
a takes B6 and now the really really
clever move C6
noticing that this Pawn is overworked
this Pawn has to control two things it
has to stop you from this going here and
from going here because now that I'm on
C6
if I take
this Pawn runs
and if I don't
this Pawn gets home so that's a really
kind of very simple Elementary example
and even though now black has two past
bonds it doesn't matter because ours is
closer
and we're going to be able to use a
queen to pick off whatever pawns we need
to
um so anything you can do to create a
past Pawn even if you have to break
through now this would be a different
example if white spawns were down here
and black spawns are up here because
then even if we break through black is
still going to be closer so you do want
to be aware of how close someone is to
promotion
um but yeah another really important
idea is looking at some of these types
of breakthroughs
finally one quick note is again with the
Rooks and the pawns so with Pawn
promotion
Rooks nine out of ten times belong
behind the past Pawn
the reason for this is well there's a
few ideas one if you try and defend it
from the side I mean in this example we
would have to get a little more creative
than that because we're going to get a
back rank but
um if you're trying to defend the pawn
from the side the problem you run into
is then anytime it moves you're no
longer controlling it with your Rook so
your Rook is gonna you're gonna have to
control it another way and then move the
rook and Shuffle and it's just a really
awkward process
if you want to try and control it from
the front
again let's do something like this
then this is going to work a little
better but unfortunately at some point
your Pawn is actually going to get stuck
The Rook is actually in the way
so the best way to defend it when
possible is to move the Rook behind the
pass Pawn because now we can push it
safely knowing that our root control is
not only the pawn but also every Square
it's going to go without getting in the
way
so if you have a choice upon where to
put a rook to help support a pass pawn
put it behind
and this is true sorry whether you're
attacking or defending
if white plays you know this
move to try and defend it from the other
side or from the side however they
choose now Black's work gets the same
benefit they're attacking this Pawn on
the Square it's on right now and every
Square will go to so putting Rooks
behind past pawns is a really good idea
that is all the time we have for tonight
but thank you so much for joining
um hopefully you learned something about
pawns that maybe you didn't know before
or maybe you knew it all but thanks for
coming anyway please stick around our
next lecture will be by Grandmaster
Alexander yermolinski should be really
fun so feel free to stick around and
enjoy it and I hope to see you again
soon
[Music]
thank you